okay new game against them
Norris from from Norway the Kings Indian
which had to be known is set up
eventually
now black very often then goes for
Bishop h6 it doesn't so I can counselor
comfortably
the structure with them taking on d5 of
the e pond isn't played that often but
it's some not easy for black to to play
in the long run his star has got some
issues with the bishop on c8 which
doesn't have a really good square he can
donate a five but we should buy five but
this is also not easy this surprising
move what would he do after Bishop f4
somehow I suspect 9h five to give up an
exchange other moves really wouldn't
make any sense I guess oh he just he
just didn't expect this move no idea but
well Knight h5 is not really a correct
sacrifice but it would at least give
some chances would like to maybe go
Knight f4 or try something on the dark
squares which are are pretty weekend I'm
sorry for the technical issue here um
which I would say bit weakened a bit
really really only two to resign the
game but let's take the points and move
on to the next game